the new york giants have to find a way
to be competitive without one of the
best running backs in football saquon
barkley an ankle injury last year that
he kept trying to play through even
though it wasn't a hundred percent now
he has the kind of injury you can't play
through the torn acl that was confirmed
today and shireen the bigger picture
here and this is something sims and i
talked about today in that financial
dance that happens between a running
back and his team when you're a great
running back you've got to get paid
after your third season how can the
giants justify paying saquon barkley
until they know that he's back to being
the guy he was case in point jerick
mckinnon after he joined the 49ers he
had to tour an acl the next year it
wasn't right they had to fix it again
they have to see saquon barkley being
the guy he was before they make that
long-term investment i think barkley's
just going to have to accept the fact
that he's going to have to wait now that
even though most running backs who are
in his class should get their contract
before they get on the season for the
third year with barclay or fourth year
excuse me with barkley this this sets
everything back now
and and i think at some level calls into
question his future with the giants
because if they wait for him to come
back
and prove that he's healthy along the
way he could get hurt again and this is
two out of three years with significant
injuries for saquon barkley and
durability is such an important part of
the running back position
you've got to prove that you're healthy
you've got to prove that you can do it
and that's going to be one of the big
ifs that the giants monitor going
forward
yeah he's scheduled to make just under a
million dollars next year in base salary
and and you can't justify giving him a
new deal an extension especially when
they had the fifth year option on him
but you know he had the two 000 yards
from scrimmage his first season looked
great won
offensive rookie of the year and then
came back last year and had the injury
and now this year he's only going to
play two games so there is a question
about his injury history and what a
terrible two games that he had after
week one he was criticized by giants
great tiki barber questioning whether he
should be in every down back because he
didn't want to block and he had to
defend himself against that and then he
comes back this week and has the injury
so it's just a a complete waste of a
season for saquon barkley and now he
faces a really really crucial 2021 and
and what his future holds and i think
you look at what michael david smith
says too about running backs they're
basically most of them are a dime a
dozen and you shouldn't draft a running
back that high and you shouldn't count
on a running back and you shouldn't pay
a running back because you can find
running backs all over the place and you
look what leonard fournette did for the
box after the jags kicked him to the
curb
well and look at what the jags are doing
with an undrafted rookie out of illinois
state and james robinson who has been
solid for them in a win and in a game
that they pushed the tennessee titans
one of the afc finalists all the way to
the wire so you know i remember saying
this about aaron foster undrafted and
rushing champion you can get running
backs at every round of the draft and
when you take a guy in the top 10 like
mccaffrey like barkley you're buying
into the idea that he is going to be
durable and of course you have no idea
that he's going to be durable until he
gets to the next level sometimes they
are sometimes they aren't
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports